hey everybody and welcome to an
outrageous wild ride with stevo
outrageous is a tall term and that is
precisely what this episode delivers
we've got the wildest guy there is maybe
i mean he is a new jackass cast member
for a reason because he is outrageous we
are going to get into the craziest stuff
like how he got his name
poopies and the devastating shark attack
he suffered on jackass shark week man
are we gonna
tell you how heartbreaking that whole
situation remains
god it's tough and we're gonna get into
his financials his i mean dude this is
the wildest character and again his name
is poopies so i could not be more
thrilled to tell you that this episode
is sponsored by my favorite sponsor of
the wild ride podcast
tushy
yeah dude tushy is the secret to the
most enjoyable pooping possible they've
got this new product called tushy ace
which is a whole toilet seat that warms
up it warms the water that you blast
your butthole with because of course
it's a bidet
you just get done pooping and the seats
warm you
push the remote control and then pull
you blast your butthole so clean that
one little square of toilet paper just
to dry it off and see that there's no
poop on the paper i'm telling you it's
my favorite go to hellotushy.com
stevo for 10 off your order and if you
don't have tushy already then listen to
me go to hellotushi.como
for 10 off your order i'm telling you
it's my favorite sponsor of the wild
ride podcast and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
poopies
what's up
so your real name
sean patrick mcinerney
mac and mcinerney yeah irish irish boy
gun in my head i wouldn't have been able
to say that yeah they used to call me
mac nerdy
um mcturdy's
yeah yeah i was before poopies oh right
dirty dead preston said the funniest
joke he said uh poopy's father when he
was a young boy said don't get smart
with me
and poopies took it literally
i'm so smart i mean dude are you
actually uh
you're actually pretty dumb huh
well
it's not like it's not my fault
right i just i got the cards you know
the cards got dealt to me and i got to
play them so and i say that with like
such love
and affection i i really think that
i do i really mean it like there's
poopy's just so lovably dumb
yeah man it's weird it's weird it's just
me i mean that's just me i mean yeah
you're just and you're lovable you got a
heart of gold thank you thank you i mean
like my mom raised me and she always you
know said treat others like you want to
be treated and everyone's equal and
so that's how i go about life and right
treat people how you want to be treated
and we all want to be treated good and
so i mean that's that's why where i get
my
my love from yeah
um i met her mom the other night and she
was just as lovely as could be i mean i
really really was stoked to meet her
yeah she's the best dude like
she prays for me every day
she's always texting me love you hope
you're having a great day like every day
right yeah she's the best she
she's
she's there for me when i'm like you
know and the lowest of lows and
you know she's my mama what's the lowest
of lows give us an example of a low the
low below is like you go out say you get
a paycheck on friday
you go cash it
meet up with the boys
send it all weekend long like freaking
drinking drugs and then sunday comes
around
and you're broke it's like then saturday
morning comes around yeah yeah
friday afternoon
there's definitely like times where i
was like spent my money in one night for
sure but yeah the lowest lows is when
you just like you have nothing dude you
like
your serotonin's gone your money's gone
your your your friends are nowhere to be
found you know it's like [ __ ] sad
it's like the world blows yeah it's like
right and then you you just really like
you realize that you're like dude i
don't have [ __ ] right now i'm like
before jackass what were your paychecks
for
um before jack house i was working for
um red bull tv i was doing a web series
for them we didn't wait with the jamie
o'brien yeah the j.o.b show who's joe b
the jrb show yeah so your checks came
from red bull for that they came from a
production company i mean dude given
like how little
like
basic cable networks like mtv comedy
central isn't that like how notoriously
little mtv pays
i got to believe that red bull tv
wasn't paying you [ __ ] nothing dude
especially when it wasn't even your show
you were like a sidekick guy yeah i was
like the sidekick guy who did all the
crazy [ __ ] for free so did you get uh
paid per stunt or per episode or no it
was like per month yeah per month yeah i
was getting 500 bucks a month when it
first started all right so when you mean
like send it with the boys that's like
one round of drinks and you're [ __ ]
at rock bottom yeah 500 bucks and would
taxes come out of that um yeah taxes
would come out so it would be like what
a check for like 350 bucks yeah like
nothing really and then in hawaii the
living is really expensive so luckily
jamie would put me up in his house
but i'd pretty much be
scraping by like
lunch lunch would consist of a pokeball
eight dollar pokeball and a dollar
ninety-nine cent iced tea that was my
lunch and then luckily the hawaiians
loved the barbecue so i would always be
sniffing out the barbecues you know
so that always helped you know but find
yourself a little backyard yeah yeah
they're always barbecuing but yeah i was
scraping by in hawaii and then finally
the the checks got more and more every
every year so at the end checks from red
bull got more and more for the
production company yeah
because i was just like they they knew
they were kind of maybe taking advantage
they knew that you were the golden goose
they knew i was the golden goose who
would just do it for fun and love to do
it you know so they they didn't really
say anything they goes oh you know let's
just keep them going you know right
right because i love to travel the world
and that's what we're doing we're
traveling the world and surfing the best
waves in the world with all my best
friends you know so that was [ __ ]
awesome to me you ever have a real job
dude
i've worked so many [ __ ] jobs it's
gnarly okay so i dropped out of high
school when i was a sophomore was over
school i'd my dad would drop me off and
that was before
you're a sophomore you're 15 years old
uh-huh
it was when you were 16 years old that
you got the nickname poopies yeah yeah i
wonder how many people know this who are
listening
so it so poopies came before i dropped
out
oh sorry so poopies came like freshman
year i guess you were 14 and you got the
name yeah poopies came freshman year and
then
well let's tell people how you got the
nickname poopy oh yeah yeah it's a great
we're not gonna water it down no we
won't so yeah
so [ __ ] jackass was thriving we were
thriving on it it was the mtv series
every friday night at 10 p.m 20 years
ago yeah 20 years ago now 35 okay so
we're talking 21 years ago yeah so i was
four yeah 14 15 and
dude we loved it we're [ __ ] we're
inspired inspired so inspired and we are
all surfers and we like to do dumb [ __ ]
and at this point you're living in
carlsbad california yeah at this point
i've been living in carlsbad california
san diego county yup san diego county
north county
i had a house on acacia street on
garfield and acacia
and i lived next to the beach and
[ __ ] i would just like
pretty much
at that time after i dropped out i got a
construction job because i was at the
surface that's why you said this was
before you dropped out this was right
after i dropped out so i was like [ __ ]
school my name's poopies no one likes me
no no no we're talking about before you
tell them
yeah okay okay
he's trying to sidestep this one that's
great
okay let's get back to it you're in an
intersection and you wanted to impress
your dumb buddies yeah you were inspired
by jackass you pulled down your parents
and took a dump at an intersection in
the middle of the road yeah so the next
day we all woke up i think we stay i
stay tonight at my friend's house that
morning we woke up there's no waves
we're [ __ ] bored and
my friend's like dude let's do something
stupid i was like i gotta take a [ __ ]
right now he's like dude
my name was sean sean go take a [ __ ] in
the middle of the intersection and we'll
[ __ ] watch you and hopefully did they
video it dude we have the video
but i can't find it someone was videoing
but i think they got too scared when the
cops showed up because the neighbors
called the cops um they called my god
how long are you [ __ ] for
dude not that long at all so you were
done
it was the hype up i was so nervous to
get into the street so we're all hanging
out on the corner of the sidewalk you
know and i i found a gorilla mask and
gorilla gloves ah you took a [ __ ] as a
gorilla yeah so i went to my friend's
closet i was like [ __ ] what can i find
to hide my face you know
so i found a gorilla mask gorilla gloves
and we're all walking out to the streets
like it's pretty much like 20 feet from
my friend's house so we're all in the
corner i'm like [ __ ] should i do this or
not should i do this or not did you get
a big log dude you know what's funny is
i was pooping and i had to pinch it off
because i seen the cops coming ah wow
they came that quick they came because
the neighbors were like he had to go get
the [ __ ] mask and check this yeah
okay so like so i see the cops coming i
pinch it off and i pull up my pants and
then all my friends did this they just
bail they're out because they're not
your friends they they
they're they are i don't know they're
not on meth now
no no
they all have families and they're doing
well but okay
cops pull up i'm like tripping out i try
to ditch my gorilla mask and gloves and
act like nothing's going on like excuse
me sir get over here please did they put
handcuffs on you yeah they handcuffed me
and then the neighbor came out and told
them what was happening and they go well
we're gonna call your dad because you're
too young to you know right to freaking
put you in jail so they call my dad and
my dad comes down he's all pissed off
he goes what the [ __ ] going on
yeah papa poo dude he came in hot what
the [ __ ] going on well your son was
over here taking a [ __ ] in the street
and um yeah the neighbors called the
cops and uh now we have him here and you
guys and he takes me by my he grabs me
by my shirt he's like
he tells the cops he's like i'll deal
with him when we get home i was like
he's like dragging me dude and then
[ __ ] we get in the truck his truck he
goes
whoa we got a cliffhanger and before we
find out what papa poo said in that
vehicle let me tell you what's gonna
happen in the vehicle we recorded this
podcast in that's right the rv slash
tour bus is getting a modification in
the form of a new mattress in my main
bedroom because i do not ever want to
sleep on any mattress except the one
from helix sleep.com that's right man
i'm not gonna put up with it anymore i
need my helix sleep.com mattress and i'm
telling you so do you and if you want to
get up to 200 off of any helix mattress
then go to helix sleep.com
stevo take a quick two minute quiz to
get dialed in with precisely the best
mattress for you and enjoy a happier
healthier night's sleep on a nightly
basis
feeling good and feeling good about what
you paid because again helixsleep.com
for up to 200 off of any mattress and
they throw in two free pillows telling
you do it for yourself you're gonna
thank me and let's get back to papa poo
poopies that was the funniest it was at
sean at the time he got sean that was
the funniest [ __ ] i've ever [ __ ]
heard of and he i was like i'm not in
trouble he goes no you're not in trouble
i was like [ __ ] yeah so that's when dad
started supporting my [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ] yeah when uh
did you find out that you were actually
in legal trouble for that
um when um
they gave me a ticket
when do you make the conscious decision
like you wake up and you're like
i'm not going to school anymore for the
rest of my life you were 15 yeah i was
15 to sophomore year half a sophomore
year cause my name became poopies and i
hated school cause i'd show up to school
what's your poopies like did they just
rub it in so it was before whether we've
had that you got the name poopies before
you dropped out and then we got it it
was afterwards
ago dude a lot happened
after he got the name he keeps going to
school and they're calling you poop yeah
[ __ ] in the street went back to school
was the kid who's [ __ ] in the street and
that's why they called you
yes and every chick did not want to even
talk to me i never went to one prom one
um homecoming not even one of those so
you didn't like the name at first but i
hated the name dude and my friends were
dicks at the time and they you know when
you don't like your name
where you don't like something like that
yeah
you know you're for sure it sticks when
you're like [ __ ] you guys stop calling
me that oh
[ __ ] i shouldn't have even said that
because
you should have said you loved it right
away and then they would have never
called you that my friends were such
dicks dude i'd be skateboarding around
doing like little surf turns you know
and every turn i do they'd
i go so [ __ ] pissed dude i'm just
trying to skate around you know and then
every trying to go they go
and dude it pissed me the [ __ ] off so i
stopped going to school and i'd go to
the surf shop so my dad would drop me
off at school
and i'd have my beach cruiser and i'd
wait for him to leave and i'd [ __ ]
turn my bike straight down to the beach
so your dad didn't know you were
dropping out he didn't know when did he
find out like a month later and then he
was like
because i gave the school the wrong
number
to call you know because you call your
parents boy so i gave him the wrong
number you're not that dumb after all
yeah i was like [ __ ] you i'm getting
away with this you know i'm like not
going to school going to the surf shop
surfing all day and how old were you
when you moved from missouri to
california i was in eighth grade so when
was the first time you surfed
the first time i surfed i used to visit
in the summer time
to visit my dad in the summertime so the
first time i surfed i think i was in
like fifth grade sixth grade
and then you just took to it like yeah
because i met the surfer the surfing
local kids when i come visit in the
summer and then i moved and they're like
[ __ ] yeah you moved here i was like yeah
so that's when i was just hanging out
with the surf rats all day and became a
surf rat yeah why did you move to
california so i moved to california
because my brother um i was i was really
like
look i looked up to my brother a lot and
he was like a really good wrestler
so he was like the best wrestler on the
high school team in missouri and him and
his friend were in the candy store and
they stole candy and he got kicked off
the wrestling team
so he was devastated you know my dad's
like oh well [ __ ] dude
you can come out to california and
wrestle you know so
so that's when my dad drove a u-haul to
missouri and picked me my brother up and
drove us back to california
and then he my uncle registered me into
um
so my uncle signed me up for junior high
right okay and um yeah that's what
because i showed up dude bugle boy shirt
short jean shorts and girls adidas like
they're like who the [ __ ] is this kid
and i i wanted to fit in so bad dude i
started [ __ ] throwing pine cones at
cars
straight out of missouri
john pine cones at cars like who the
[ __ ] is this why'd you do that
attention yeah dude attention seems like
i get it so you know i was i wanted to
be the people i want to be one of the
popular kids and i guess that was my way
of trying to get it but so you became
poopies like when you were like 15. yeah
freshman year became people yes
sophomore you go back to school you like
you know your sophomore they call you
poopies now you don't like it don't like
it at all so you
stop going to school yeah stop going to
school i started hanging out the surf
shop how how quickly after that did you
go to hawaii
uh not for a while oh not for so so when
i when i dropped out of high school i
worked out i kind of worked at the surf
shop you know if you hang out the surf
shop and you're supposed to be at school
you better be sweeping the floors or
[ __ ] cleaning the shaping bay or
doing something productive you know to
help out the shop
so i ended up meeting this guy who was
working construction who lived at the
surf shop and he got me a construction
job
okay so i was making [ __ ] pretty good
money and i wasn't even like 18. i think
i just turned 18
and i and i got my first job and on a
construction site doing track homes in
lacosta all those alga houses
and in la costa i built all those so i
helped build i was the laborer
good so but [ __ ] dude you guys are gonna
love this one so i was killing it right
and then the guy who
the guy who um
got me the job got fired because he ran
over a fire extinguisher with the petty
bones like a big forklift
so they're like [ __ ] poopies he kind of
taught you how to drive the paddy bone i
was like yeah i can drive the thing you
know this huge ass heavier machinery
i'm [ __ ] driving around picking up
nails and [ __ ] plywood on the roofs
like i'm killing it and then they bring
in this new pedi bone and i wasn't used
to it and you have to some you have to
pull the parking brake and the
hydraulic brake
well this one i wasn't used to so i go
up to the top of this hill and there's
the bin you know we get all the nails
and all the [ __ ] for the framers so i'm
getting all the [ __ ] for the framers i
walk into the bin and i [ __ ] come out
and go who the [ __ ] took my petty bone
bro the mexicans are pointing at it
they're like your petty bones down here
bro i forgot to put on the break the
thing went backwards dude down this hill
almost took out a house took out this
masonry wall and i i was like dude this
is gnarly dude and i look at the
pedigree the wheels are all [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] and then
dude it was like the boss i see the boss
coming up the hill with this truck
i'm like bro i didn't know i forgot to
put the hydraulic brake on he goes
here you go sean i think it's it's time
for you to
to um
take you know
to beat it
he's like beat it kook and i was like
[ __ ] yeah unemployment summer time let's
go
all right i was stoked on that
but i almost took out a [ __ ] like
million dollar house that wasn't even
built yet um when when you were 18 what
did you see yourself doing in life like
would you want to be when you got older
i have no i wanted to be a pro surfer
and and when you were working that
construction job
your boss called you poopies
no at that time yeah so i didn't let
anyone know my name was poopies because
i hated it he still didn't like it so i
try to hide that name so when did uh
but at any year he references if he's
two he's like my mom called me poopies
get off the couch
at four his dad said
so when did you embrace the name poopies
dude so when i went to hawaii you're
still conflicted about it i know yeah
dude
did you did you did does your tinder say
poopies now
no it says sean because i'm still weird
about the when like i meet chicks dude i
don't go high on poopies i go hi i'm
sean and then my friends goes what
that's not your name his name's poopies
i'm like dude shut the [ __ ] up yeah
you're like dude i'm trying to crush
some beevo yeah dude i need some puss
you guys are getting laid i didn't lose
my virginity until i was 19. because my
name was poopies
no [ __ ] joke it's kind of like an
icebreaker or something like a man
why is your name poopy's oh he took a
[ __ ] in the street yeah they don't get
the jackass thing that you know they're
like
we were just that savage we loved it and
no one else liked it you know because
they're all jocks and [ __ ] we're their
surfers and skaters we loved it but the
jocks and all the hot chicks that you
want to hook up with they don't like
that [ __ ] so yeah it was definitely like
a
definitely a [ __ ] block for me i mean
it's a great name
i love it now like i [ __ ] love my
name now like except when you're trying
to crush beef
well now they go
wait you're poopies
and now it's like whole 360. i'm like
yeah baby
yeah i'm poopies that's what's up yeah
but now it's a whole 360 which is i
gotta still stay humble you know you
can't take that power too far but
you know when they call me poopies i'm
like yeah you know and then they go but
there's it's funny i've i've known
people for like two years and they go so
what's your real name
like they won't even know my real name
for like two times sean mcinerney yep
right yeah wow yeah good job attention
it's like two names mac and ernie yeah
sean patrick
ernie yeah
when i got your hotel tonight i was like
sean i was like [ __ ] i just put mgm jam
gm
i gotta go explain that when we go to
the hotel tonight yeah for sure so
construction was great and then i got a
better offer
to smuggle drugs across the tijuana
board wow allegedly you got allegedly
yeah i mean whatever dude says you're a
mule yeah it was a meal you had drugs um
hash
okay yeah so hash huh over the mexican
border yeah from mexico to us or us to
mexico so the old the old dude uncle
danny i don't think a lot of people are
smuggling drugs into mexico okay fair
enough yeah
i probably wouldn't say any names either
yeah yeah oh he's past it he's he's up
in heaven now okay uncle danny dude he
was this old-timer that lived at the
surf shop and he was a porto escondido
local like when we go to porto you get
you know so what was your method scott
loves asking uh like rock stars how they
would smuggle drugs or what was your
method oh dude i got the best method
ever it worked so good keister no no no
i would not how'd your butthole end up
so [ __ ] up
i've never even seen my butthole before
i don't know we have i know
you guys love my butthole dude yeah um
so yeah how do you smuggle so this old
guy was at the surf shop you know he
would visit the surf shop and i'm like
he's in and out so but he's super cool
we weren't even 21 yet we'd like hey can
you buy some beers you'd be like yeah
for sure but we'd always be like a
dollar short you'd get so pissed but um
so he passed away
and they asked me they go poopies you
want to take over uncle danny's job and
i kind of knew what he did
and i was like [ __ ] dude i was like well
what do we got to do he's like well you
gotta smuggle hash across the border and
we'll pay you two g's
how much hash
four kilos wow that's more than you can
fit in your butt yeah
is that like 10 pounds
2.2 pounds per kilo four
yeah that's just about almost it's 8.8
pounds or
yeah something yeah almost ten pounds
pounds that's a lot that's like uh four
ziploc bags yeah so it was all wrapped
up but um so
as [ __ ] i'll do it you know i i was like
[ __ ] it i'll do it i was dumb as [ __ ]
dude how old were you 18. that's like
life
said that you're okay whatever yeah 18.
so after construction after okay so i
got fired from that and then i was like
[ __ ] i was kind of in the in the way
8.8 pounds of cash so my friend my
friend
lives in laguna beach and um he was kind
of part of the deal too so i was i took
over uncle danny's spot which he's the
best smuggler in the world so they had
their you know they had their ways of
doing it so i met up with this guy um in
a hotel tijuana hotel like the nice one
and i'd go up to his room and he'd have
these pajamas like um
like
john's it would be sewn into the pajamas
yep pockets sewn into the long johns so
i put on the long johns and then he'd
put these bricks of hash on me straight
out of that movie the wolf of wall
street right
midnight express
yeah yeah yeah it was [ __ ] crazy so
my first time i'm like dude what the
[ __ ] am i
doing can't go the first time so
so yeah the first time so i was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing but when did
you wear anything over the long jump
yeah so yeah they put all the hash on me
and they tape it all up so you're
dressed up like you're going to [ __ ]
ski resort but it's actually tijuana
where it's like super warm you're the
only guy i've dressed for winter
and this was the thing you gotta wear
loose clothing over it
so i look like some [ __ ] weirdo with
loose clothing and we're gonna make
boobs oh dude so i would they tape it up
on me put on the loose clothing and
they'd be like all right well now let's
go get some drinks
so i'd go out and tj and have drinks
with all this strapped on me to get
comfortable with it right right right so
you don't want to be too nervous going
yeah yeah so i would just be off wasted
you know like yeah we're partying
dude they don't even know i have [ __ ]
eight pounds of hash on me and then i go
through the borderline with all the
party kids
and they're like what are you doing here
oh i'm just partying you know and
they're like all right grandpa are you
thinking like man a dog might smell this
dude
so all they would have to do is just
touch me and they would feel it and dude
they'd have dogs right there too i just
like kind of just not looking at you
there were dogs when you had that much
hat strapped to you yeah the dog didn't
nope
it was it was no smell
they're really good at what they do uh
so they were packing it in like vacuum
sealed bags yeah so they bring it from
porto they'd make it in porto in the
oaxaca mountains okay so she got through
without any issues yeah i got through
without
two grand for that one walk across the
border
and how many times did you do that i did
that twice
but the second time was so sketch dude
like i thought i was gonna get busted
but luckily i didn't
and i [ __ ] made it through and
i have to have it still on me too when i
have to make it up like
at least past north county with it so
and then finally they cut it off me i
get get to this guy's house they cut it
all off me dude i could [ __ ] breathe
dude because i couldn't breathe dude
with it all on me and [ __ ] and i have to
like suck in and like show them my
passport and like yo
i'm just here partying like trying to
suck it all in dude it was [ __ ]
gnarly damn how much of the two grand
would you spend in tijuana that night oh
i wouldn't get paid until i made it all
the way oh okay yeah i'd go straight to
7-eleven grab slurpees all the candy all
the hot dogs for all my boys
we were living large at that surf shop
after a run for real yeah it was gnarly
but yeah dude that was the smuggling
[ __ ] and i was over that dude
so i started going up north to trimweed
trim weed yeah so i was working on a
farm so how much you get paid to trim
weed like 200 bucks a day and they feed
you and house you so the whole time
you're just saving money
and that's uh
how much can you trim in a day i can
trim like a pound in a day like it's
like 200 bucks a pound you know
so i trim like a pound a day but it
would take me [ __ ] all [ __ ] day
long like it sucked so i did that for a
few years so i'd go up north from
from like august to october
and trim for like three two months
excuse me
so i'd go up there trim save my money
and i'd go to hawaii with my trim money
and that's how i made it to hawaii every
every winter so my goal was before my
birthday i'd have to make it to hawaii
before my birthday
she was when you
got to hawaii that you met
jamie o'brien yeah not not uh two years
after actually my first winner i didn't
meet him then my second winner i met him
okay how did you meet him
um i was actually hanging out with his
filmer damian robertson and we're
kicking it you know
um he's kind of like hey i'll film a
couple clips for you if you get a good
one i was like sick cool and then i
found out he's jamie's filmer i'm like
what you're [ __ ] jamie o'brien's
filmer you're like yeah you want to come
over and hang out we're going to
barbecue tonight and so i came over
and um they go yeah this is damian goes
yeah this is my friend poopy's and jamie
goes what your name's poopies were you
bummed that he introduced you as poopies
kind of because i was trying to so when
i went to hawaii i was trying to get rid
of my nickname i went to i was like yes
there's no more poopies and my friend
thiago he's like bro his name's poopies
you guys
don't let him tell you his name's not
boobies i was like [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ] i tried to get rid of
that name i tried to escape the name and
it followed me dude to hawaii yeah so
they're like [ __ ] why they call you
poopy as a tom story you know but it was
funny because james he told the whole
story
[Applause]
but no jamie it was funny because jamie
kind of felt bad for me he's like dude
i'm not gonna call you poopies i'm gonna
call you sean a week later he's like
your name's [ __ ] dude you sweep the
floors [ __ ] do the dishes
and we'll [ __ ] go surf a little bit
so yeah and and he was already making
the red bull shower now he made one
movie his own surf movie that came out
on dvd and then red bull it kind of did
good so red bull was like well let's try
a web series that's when like web series
were first coming out
so so we started the web series and it's
[ __ ] took off and they just loved us
seeing us travel dude
before anybody had any clue that you
were on jackass
you were already surf royalty like when
i was at kelly slater's surf ranch
i was like dude
we're making a new jackass movie and we
got poopies in it every single person
was like no way
like you're well known in the surf
industry yeah i mean i send it it's my
my kind of um title in the surf world
is like boobies
but it's not like i'm not the pro surfer
you know right right right i'm not the
pro servers getting all the money from
all the sponsors all the chicks and
stuff i'm poopies who is sending it for
[ __ ]
100 bucks a [ __ ] day you're kind of
like in surfing what i used to be in
skateboarding i would be the guy in the
videos doing anything but skateboarding
yeah yeah well yeah i mean exactly
because you just want to be one of the
boys you know well i wanted to be in
skate videos and i wasn't that good at
skating so i let myself on fire and
shoved things up my butt yeah i love it
yeah um so see you become famous i'm
famous in the surf world strictly from
jamie o'brien's
red bull series and then his youtube
channel yeah so after the web series we
did that for eight years
um jamie's like let's we're not going to
give red bull any of our content we're
starting our own youtube channel and
he's done very well with that oh he's
done so well so
how did you go from that to jackass you
met tripp taylor yeah so i met tripp
taylor when i was 16 in carlsbad
california at the surf shop that he's
hanging out at wow cause he was trying
to do a um show for my friend adam knox
he's putting together a reel for him
and it was super boring until i showed
up because they called me like we got
this one kid his name's poopies he'll
[ __ ] send it so they call me up like
poopies we're gonna film something you
want to come i was like [ __ ] yeah it's
funny too because it's still on youtube
you can see how [ __ ] nervous i am i'm
like hi i'm poopy's
[ __ ] is [ __ ] classic but i i sent it
for them and and the show never got
picked up
and tripp saw my success with red bull
tv and seen all this crazy [ __ ] i did
and he came to me one day he's like
poopies they're looking for new talent
for jackass i go shut the [ __ ] up
because i'm trying to get you in don't
get your hopes up i was like i'm not i'm
not and then all of a sudden i get a
call from tripp hey i got you a skype
call with knoxville and jeff germain and
i was like shut the [ __ ] up like i was
so nervous dude i was counting the days
i think i had seven days until that
skype call dude i was so [ __ ] nervous
until that moment came on then they boom
hey poopies how's it going from
knoxville and jeff jeremy i'm like what
what's up you guys like i'm freaking out
inside but we had like a 10 minute skype
call they're like we're flying you out
to la to come do a test shoot
and it [ __ ] went fabulous and that's
when they said poopies you are made for
this yeah i wasn't there at that test i
was like where the [ __ ] stevo yeah i
wasn't there i i was trying to uh hold
out for a better contract so i was
playing hardball with yeah playing
hardcore
and uh
and but i heard from everybody after
that test shoot and everybody said dude
this new guy poopies is going to be the
breakout star of this he's so [ __ ]
funny
so i heard such glowing [ __ ] about you
from that test shoot dude everyone said
you were going to be it you're going to
start yeah i was a trip dude i went
there and i was like i'm not holding
back like i was volunteering for every
stunt
and they're like dude this kid's [ __ ]
is he mentally crazy or what like i was
like no i'll do it i'll do it so i mean
that was my point in my time in my life
is i have this opportunity and i don't
want to [ __ ] let it go so i had to
like try my hardest and
pretty much put my life on the line
the thing too it was so great like i was
talking with preston lacy the other day
i talked to preston every day and he
only says great things about poopies and
you know what i only say great things
about athletic greens man i've told you
before i use this every day but candidly
today was a gnarly day dude i started at
8 15 in the morning with radio
interviews i was all over florida
doing just work all day and i somehow
didn't get around to doing what i'm
doing right now which is dumping my
athletic greens into a cup of water
better late than never man and what's
athletic greens well
it is like a supplement which you can
take on a completely empty stomach first
thing in the morning it's loaded with 75
different vitamins minerals probiotics
like
just so much healthy stuff it fills in
all of the gaps in my crappy diet and
lately that's an important thing i'm
telling you plus it tastes absolutely
delicious
i mean it's good for gut health it's
good for
digestion it's good for nutrition and
it's just downright delicious i i use it
every single day it's called athletic
greens and if you go to
athleticgreens.com
you're gonna get
five of these travel packs totally for
free and they're gonna give you an
entire year's supply of immune boosting
vitamin d
you can't beat it man i swear by it i
love it it's delicious it's healthy and
you can't pass up this deal go to
athleticgreens.com
devo five free travel packs a year
supply of vitamin d it's a great deal
and get on it so while i pound this
let's hear about how much everybody
loves poopies
and and i was like
like what because you genuinely are the
the breakout star of the movie you know
i i i really think that that's safe to
say and i was freshman i was saying like
dude like poopies doesn't even have like
in jackass forever like that one
signature solo bit that's like
like you don't even put it in they
didn't put it in what was it
it was called oh i'll show i'll show me
yeah i'll show me did i love that what
is that oh dude he's standing on a
stepladder with a [ __ ] sledgehammer
he's on the top right he goes oh show me
he swings the stepladder down snogs it
out from beneath him and then lands on
his [ __ ] face that's amazing i was
afraid i was going to break my neck
dude it looked like you broke your dude
i went straight like i can't believe
this
is the best because that test shoot
maybe people don't realize a lot of that
ended up in the movie
that was what that's like all the stuff
at dirt x plays
the air bag musical chairs
man does the flip was from the test
shoot yeah the dumb dumb game was from
the test shoes is hilarious in that yeah
the ping pong
people were they uh penis ping pong
where they flattened the wieners
that was the test shoot the human ramp
with the yeah all the guys stacked up
that the test shoe was like unbelievably
productive there's so much everything we
got so much [ __ ] done in those two days
it was crazy yeah
yeah it's it's insane is there anything
that you won't do
like swim with sharks again or something
would you not jump sharks again unless i
have a [ __ ]
protective shirt no i'm just joking that
was crazy
i'm not [ __ ] with sharks anymore dude
i'm like i [ __ ] tested my boundaries
and
luckily i still have my hand for four uh
people who didn't catch the jackass
shark week episode
i i think but probably uh like a lot of
people know you got badly bitten by a
shark yeah i mean it was can you show
the camera yeah dude it was it was crazy
as [ __ ] thing i know i felt bad for
you guys because you had to go through
it but [ __ ] i was just like yeah how
dare you do that
that's what he was worried about in the
hospital was so so it's [ __ ] still on
but dude
it's [ __ ] gnarly though which camera
should you show up
it looks like your hand has been like
like burned like freddy krueger yeah
burned that's that's funny because i say
that i tell people it looks like freddy
krueger's face like yeah yeah it's so
gnarly it was crazy as papa poops has a
missing hand on the same hand yeah did
you know that steve his dad is missing a
hand
yeah that's right that's right his poops
always took after his dad my dad got his
hand um ran over by a train let's put
into perspective how [ __ ] obvious it
was that that was gonna happen dude
this was the thing i had one
i had just i didn't have any practice
runs
well i mean if i would have got a
practice run a couple practices run with
no sharks i made it
no i could've got no sharks i could have
gone it wouldn't have happened
technically if he would have landed it
and ridden away
okay so here's the thing like and it
really
like was like supposed to be me because
the bigger bit was a dunk tank built on
on barrels so it was floating so that
the actual tank was the ocean with all
the sharks and i was just
they had this dunk tank with the the
seat above the like six feet above the
water no cage underneath no cage
underneath just barrels on the water and
the seats six feet above and it's got
the target and everyone's supposed to be
throwing chunks of meat at the target
and so that the hunks of meat bring all
the sharks and then when one hunk of
meat actually hits the target it'll drop
me into the water and i thought when i
heard the idea i thought that that
sounded like the safest thing because
when we were in south africa during the
the uh great white they said if you land
on the shark then like that's the safest
thing this it'll startle the shark like
the land in the water startled the shark
it's gonna bolt so i was like oh dude
i'll be perfectly fine i'll be safe well
we get there
and
there was something about these sharks
these caribbean reef sharks doesn't
sound like a scary shark but when we
threw
a piece of meat in the water it was the
gnarliest [ __ ]
these sharks were climbing all over each
other biting everything apart
they were the most aggressive [ __ ]
sharks i've ever seen in my life yeah i
saw a leaf land on the water and it was
wow oh my god
remember when you were feeding them from
the back of the boat
ever dude they were it was [ __ ] it
was a frenzy they were gonna feel like a
friend
they put a [ __ ]
uh water ski jump ramp in the water and
now like what we're doing is we're
throwing hunks of meat
right into the to the landing in front
of the ramp so it's just the swarm of
stars
like climbing all over each other to get
that [ __ ] meat what the plus it was
dusk which is when sharks are the most
active
we're losing light and you don't want to
swim at dusk that's the most dangerous
time we've been saying dude it's dusk
like
you know and so we're throwing the the
hunks of meat in front of the ramp where
poopies is gonna land what the [ __ ] do
you think is gonna happen every time
something landed in that water
it was like the sharks were conditioned
oh here's we're feeding them right
something lands it's it's it's we eat it
and so we're throwing it we're throwing
it and then the next thing that [ __ ]
lands on that
water is poopies the [ __ ] did you think
was gonna happen
oh the only thing that has landed on
that water is food and then poopies is
the next thing to land he's food he gets
bitten was the idea that he would jump
successfully
i wanted to jump over them at least
clear them it was the most [ __ ]
hindsight it was the most reckless most
obvious [ __ ] [ __ ] that put in and had
we we were supposed to film the dunk
tank before that
and it was the same dynamic if i did the
dunk tank i would have they would've
been throwing everything's food
everything's food and then dropped the
chair and i'm food
when you hit the water
what do you remember
i just remember looking at the boys on
the boat and just
[ __ ] dude i was just like i'm [ __ ]
boys i mean we saw the sharks like he
landed on the sharks we saw them just
[ __ ] commotion is he underwater and
then we saw his hand come up out of the
water
and dude it was
i couldn't see anything instantly yeah i
couldn't say nothing because i was in
shock so i like i was trying to tell him
that i got bit but i like couldn't
really tell oh [ __ ]
i felt the gums of the mouth like it bit
my hand and i felt the top of the of its
mouth the roof of his mouth with my
fingers was all like slimy and [ __ ] and
that's when i knew i was like i'm
[ __ ] getting bit right now so like
i'm so like i fail to bite and i go [ __ ]
if i like pull my hand off it's going to
take my hand so i let him have my hand
you just gave up yeah dude i was just
like dude here's my hand bro
how slow motion this experience is
unfolding because all it was was
for real so yeah and then dude it felt
like the strongest like a full like
it felt like someone grabbed you like
with a [ __ ] robot hand and just like
you have no there's it was so powerful
and so muscular i don't know it was a
straight muscle it felt like a straight
muscle that just could just take my hand
off dude it was so [ __ ] gnarly like
the first thing that we saw like that
where like was poopy's hand come up out
of the water and it's just gushing yeah
it was all and it was just like oh [ __ ]
it was like the gnarliest thing ever and
the actual like it was a wave runner
like jet ski which the medic was driving
to tow poopies on the wakeboard off the
ramp so he was being towed yeah that was
his first toe too so so the the the
medic was driving the the jet ski tows
poopy's off the ramp sees the [ __ ]
thing and the medic is on the jet ski
turns it around
and drives straight back and dives off
my back
dives on there like dude this medic just
dove into this this mix so [ __ ] fast
saved poopies in such a big way dude
like there's no regard for himself dove
in the mix [ __ ] grab poopies [ __ ]
got just got poopies out of the water
now poopies is climbing on the boat like
if you hold your hand limp right like
hold your hand lamp vertical your hand
comes out horizontally take the stranger
so far it can go it's like your hand can
only come out horizontal but because all
of poopy's tendons were completely
severed his hand was flopped all the way
down
like all the way down flat to his
forehead
his hand was flat to his wrist you saw
this steve i saw i saw his hand flopped
all the way down as he got on the boat i
was like oh my god i try to like push up
but it like dude yeah you tried to use
your hand yeah i tried to use my hand
and then i [ __ ] lifted it up and it
fell off and i was like oh [ __ ] dude i
was like this is not good but that guy
saved my life because i don't think if
he if he didn't jump on me i would have
gotten mauled to death yeah i i don't
doubt that i don't doubt that and if
everyone didn't move so [ __ ] fast he
would have bled out definitely he had
his arteries severed was it multiple
arteries
dude i had i saw blood squirting out
like a perfect straw like you spilled
water out of the straws perfect circle
oh so you get on the boat they wrap you
up and you're gone like how quickly
the medics bag was on another [ __ ]
boat so they're like maddie backs they'd
like go
[ __ ] like and it all happened so
[ __ ] fast and the current the current
was [ __ ] so like it took me to the
side of the boat where i'm supposed to
get on it past that so now they're like
pull trying to get me on the boat and
then my wake board gets stuck between
these two yeah he's still on the wake
board and i'm still on the right board
and jeff tremaine's trying to get the
wakeboard off he goes [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] get this wakeboard off i'm like
just chill just heal i'm like just grab
me a [ __ ] towel and so they've got
the wakeboard off they got me under the
boat and i'm like just give me the
[ __ ] towel everyone's freaking out
they're like they don't know what to do
i'm just give me a [ __ ] towel i wrap
it up and i just [ __ ] hold on and i i
remember one of the camera divers he
just like just slipped just laying my
just laying my arms everybody was so
[ __ ] pro dude i just like it was it
was a double decker boat and i just went
straight to the top deck just like to
the other side of the boat top deck and
just put had my face in my hands i was
just like jesus yeah i couldn't deal
with it and
what were you thinking steve why i just
i just knew that i didn't add anything
i added no value to this situation
we had the medics we they had they got
the tourniquet going
dude they [ __ ] immediately like had a
you know the speedboat showed up
poopies was on the boat probably in less
than a minute the tourniquet was on
you know like the longest time of that
part was getting the wakeboard off i
think right and i got that off and then
it was just like speed boat medic bag
tourniquet so i had a tourniquet on this
arm
right here and then i had a turning kit
like right here
just to stop the blood flow yeah yeah
and then it [ __ ] but it wasn't like
working that well but yeah luckily they
got a i [ __ ] took a speedboat dude
dude the speedboat came in so hot to the
docks dude we almost [ __ ] like ate
[ __ ] into the docks
and that that one bumped my hand too
when we hit the dog i was like i was
like oh
10 minute boat ride to the dock and they
had they had a 10-minute boat ride to
the dock and then they had to get me in
a van which was tornadoes
20 minutes to the hospital and then they
got me in the hospital and they're on
like lunch break or something [ __ ] and i
got something dude keep in mind this is
the bahamas this is not the most capable
[ __ ] hospital right you know and but
they were they were able to stabilize
poopies at the bahamas hospital and they
were like yo
he's got to get air lifted to
uh my florida yeah you know because i
had to sign myself out of the hospital
because there's this little asian doctor
and he's like waiting on a phone call to
like get the approval for surgery i'm
like dude i'm not getting surgery in the
bahamas and poopy's dad was at the
hospital in the palms they wouldn't let
his dad in yeah they weren't like
a virus or like no you can't be in and
poop his dad was [ __ ] dude i just
wanted to see someone that i knew like
it was the worst time in my life like
dude and when that when when they get
puppies on the speedboat to take him to
the shore i'm up on the top deck and i
see poopies on the speedboat and i just
go poopies i love you dude
and uh
and [ __ ] poopies looks up he goes
[ __ ] stevo what the [ __ ] i know you
guys know he says he says yo tremaine
what the [ __ ] i better get a bonus for
this yeah
yeah
i want a [ __ ] bonus dude
did you get a bonus no
as soon as it happened the medics are
doing all their thing right you got like
tremaine's there you've got like
you know tripp taylor was there
and then you've got like the the
discovery the discovery channel people
there [ __ ] freaking out there's like
the jackass production team and then
there's the discovery production team
which was just another production
company and the guy the executive
producer for this other production
company like whoever the main guy was he
goes oh my god dude he goes dude oh my
god we just we just ended shark week
like there's oh my god like there's
never going to be truck working the
shark we had had gone on for up to that
point 30 years without ever anybody
getting bitten by a shark
and knox was like dude took us 30
minutes
[Applause]
oh yeah i mean jesus it's the best
documented shark bite clip in history
perhaps perhaps and uh and so like as
soon as this executive producer guy says
dude we just ended sharks shark they're
like the shark week's over dude we could
[ __ ] oh my god this is the worst
[ __ ] thing and i said no
immediately this is when i snapped out
of it and i was no longer like shut down
emotionally i snapped out of it i go now
i have value to add
now i felt like i hadn't had my back
dude
immediately i said i said no no the the
the worst thing the only bad thing that
can happen out of this situation is if
that footage doesn't come out
yeah because this footage will make
poopies a legend and the worst possible
tragedy would be if poopies had this
happen to him and then didn't get the
credit this has to [ __ ] come out and
and we will go to war yeah you know like
whatever like because because now they
figured that the show was going to be
shut down everything was just going to
be shut down
and [ __ ] and like i was like nah dude
i'm just i don't know that there would
be it would have been a lot of grounds
for cereal no i mean i don't want to do
that i'm not that guy anyways right they
must have had a lot of views for that
episode right i mean probably the most
it was it was humongously successful for
for
the next day we learned that not only is
shark week not shut down but we're going
to go filming poopies has been air
backed you know to my i was in surgery
ruby's had multiple surgeries to
reattach
severed arteries and tendons all my
tendons who knows how you reattach
completely severed arteries but they did
that for two of them it's just insane
and they tell us
hey guys we're going on another shark
tank
oh yeah the next day you guys went out
when you were in miami we went on
another shark dive and they're doing all
these interviews and i'm like that's
funny i'm like dude i mean
[ __ ]
that uh
yeah i was just [ __ ] hamming it up i
i was like dude [ __ ] um let's go find
the shark dog we're gonna go we gotta go
get revenge what that shark did the
poopies was not cool man and we were
going back in the water to find that son
of a [ __ ] and give him a piece of our
mind yeah you know
that was not [ __ ] cool man and we are
gonna go [ __ ] but wait wait but we're
not trying to look for for bad blood we
just want to go squash the beep let me
know that wasn't cool yeah and just
squash the beef yeah yeah yeah like and
i was like and i was like
i was like poop this is probably going
to make a full recovery and this will be
the best thing that ever happened to him
yeah he filmed that video that night at
the hotel yeah plus he got to ride his
first private jet yeah
there you go yeah it was great yeah i'm
so glad i [ __ ] survived that thing
dude are you glad it i'm glad i still
have my hand though like imagine if i
didn't have a hand dude i would have
been like [ __ ] i'm so glad you survived
that thing too
yeah yeah not sure everything you were
supposed to have it fully back in
october that was now october november
december january february march yeah
i'm still going to physical therapy so
so we're six months late and it's not
all the way back six months later dude
it's a shark bite people are like oh
sure they're like they they treat it
like it's not a shark bite it's like
they like treat it like it's a broken
wrist or something i'm like dude you
guys this thing is like this is all it
can do you know like oh my god you don't
have [ __ ] back no dude like i can do
that that and that so if you're just
listening poopy's got about 10 degrees
on going up or down on his wrist and i
can't make a fist
yeah
i can shaka
that's that's [ __ ] heartbreaking
but you've been back in the water you're
able to surf yeah yeah i [ __ ] my
first time surfing wasn't in like in
october after my birthday oh so you did
serve on schedule i did surf on schedule
and it wasn't like it wasn't really like
pumping surfing it was more like trying
to see how much weight my wrist can take
did you serve pipeline nope not yet
not yet pipelines gnarly pipelines
when i get a good pipeline barrel i'll
be so [ __ ] pumped
but we're still working on that
dude like you're you're not back your
wrist is i'm not back dude like i can't
even write a short board like i have to
soft top every time
like i said that's so [ __ ]
heartbreaking man
how did that happen i remember i felt
guilty and i had [ __ ] like no i
i felt really [ __ ]
awful about the situation and and i was
uh i was like dude [ __ ] discoveries
gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat this i knew
because when we filmed the end of that
episode they were trying to play it down
like oh yeah
recovery like this net and and i it was
really important to me
that you'd be able to tell that story
like actually as it happened and so i
reached out to
certain people who had the raw footage
yep and i got legend both underwater
camera angles all of the raw footage of
the bite all of everything everything
like the gnarliest
and the gnarly clip that discovery
didn't use it was like too gnarly for
them
yeah this stuff like so that poopies can
tell the real story of how it went down
and and i went around in one day i went
around and i filmed knoxville and
tremaine and jasper who was there
everybody who was there and i did my own
little interview with them so awesome
and then poopies did his own interview
to tell the story and we put together
this phenomenal phenomenal video about
all of our perspectives on the attack
and poopy in that poopy's telling that
was that like the first time you told
the story because poopies broke down and
[ __ ] well yeah like the first time i
told the story out of a discovery dude
that's it we're linking that [ __ ]
video you put it on your chanel
yeah yeah
that has over a million views yeah baby
hell yeah
i know you're glad you survived right
but like is there any part of you that
you're glad you got bit
there is there is dude like because like
like imagine my story is like
i [ __ ] got bit by a shark i jumped a
[ __ ] shark pit like fonzie was gonna
like fonzie did you know i like fonzie
dead now not like
yeah dude i mean foreign who can say
they jumped a [ __ ] shark pit with a
wake board and [ __ ] didn't land it
and got bit and i'm lit i'm here to tell
the story right i don't think there's
anyone in the world has ever [ __ ]
jumped a shark pit
not like you have not like me yeah yeah
and the the bite i mean yeah dude it is
heartbreaking but it's also it's it's
definitely like
as to my legacy dude it adds to my
legacy man
what are you limited in doing like we've
established that surfing pipeline is so
there's like surfing pipes short
boarding big waves um
there's there's there's times where i'm
like trying to open the door with my
keys and like i got groceries and i
can't get my keys and like are there's
times where i'm like trying to get
something on my backpack and my arm my
wrist doesn't reach that far
so there's all these little things these
little tiny things that you wouldn't
think of that would [ __ ] suck and you
told me
okay you told me that
you asked him to line you up with stem
cell therapy yeah yeah i want to go
because when you're texting with your
phone your your hand hurts you yeah so
like in the morning time it's fine like
i'll wake up in the morning and it feels
great you know and then i'll wake up
take my shower and i'll get on my phone
and when i'm on my phone it's just like
from just like texting and typing like
my emails and [ __ ] or just liking stuff
and
it just starts hurting so then i get
this ache in my hand and i get i can't
use it and then it's like [ __ ] well i
have to use it like i have to my whole
day ahead of me you know yeah you got to
be swiping on tinder
yeah
i linked you up with michael at bile
accelerator yeah you can talk to him
yeah i have i have and i'm let's give
them a shout out bio accelerator yeah
bio exhaler
accelerator yeah bio accelerator dude
i'm coming for you guys you guys are
going to help me out so much i'm so
stoked that you guys want to help me
can you do a like a push-up or is that
like two
nothing he's been practicing like with
missionary sex yeah just try to
do some pumps and yeah so yeah
the elbows if you haven't it would help
so much though because it would stretch
it and dude it would hurt so much though
but i was like i know what this is this
is good for it because it's stretching
it so now
i can [ __ ] put my wrist all the way
like that wow so straight boning like
was the best physical therapy either
yeah it was and like i would tell people
that and they thought it was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but it's a good pick-up line you
know yeah dude it would too because i'd
put so much weight on because i'm trying
to nut too and like get in that zone you
know you're like yeah come on
a lot of pressure on it and then you
know and then it's like i finally not
and it's like [ __ ] finally i gotta like
roll over and like hold my hand i'm like
oh [ __ ] babe that was great
but you're getting a frenzy yeah but
yeah i [ __ ] helped out a lot dude so
that that kind of i was like as long as
i can get my wrist to do that because i
can need to stand up on my surfboard i'm
fine and missionary helped out so much
i don't think i shouldn't be
i don't think i should have been doing
that at that time but dude i was like i
have to nut right now and yeah that's
how i like the nut is missionary so
so what what is the physical therapist
and the doctors telling you
dude
the physical therapist is so fried they
keep doing the same [ __ ] and doing the
same [ __ ] and i'm like dude it's a
[ __ ] shark bite dude it ain't no
normal injury you know my doctor's like
poopies dude
you're a [ __ ] man dude you're the man
and he helps me out i see him every
three weeks dr dan
every three weeks you're coming up to la
to go to like the foremost hand doctor
in the world yeah yeah so he has his um
his assistant which is a legend too
and he checks i go to orange county at
his office okay he checks it out but he
said it's pretty much that's all i got
that's all you're ever gonna have
fun yeah
so
that's what i wasn't hoping for but i
mean that's how it just happened is it
gonna get stronger to where you can
are you telling me you'll never be able
to surf a short board again in your life
no i will
i mean how does that girl bethany do it
what's the girl with one eye she's
gnarly dude so so i have yeah she's not
she's inspiration to me
because she's got one arm dude and she's
standing up at pipe yeah shout out to
bethany bethany hamilton you are a
legend if you can i just watched a
documentary on an airplane and i was
really [ __ ] she's gnarly dude she's
gnarly yeah she's red she's rad i've
never really got to meet her like in
person the difference for you though is
that if you land on it bad that it's
fragile it's it's like you know
yeah because look how small it is
between this arm and that arm if you're
a pipe and you wipe out your f
yeah if i yeah i can't swim yeah so so
the hand is actually a liability where
if it wasn't there there would be no
[Music]
land it breaks my heart dude it really
[ __ ] breaks my heart to to learn that
dude
we should drive traffic to his merch
channel to get him
let's get some let's get some money
coming your way because robbie's psyched
what uh like i mean this is awkward but
it's safe to say that
that you didn't get paid a whole bunch
to be in the new jackass movie
yeah we can we can say that
i mean if it kind of makes sense because
like yeah it's like it's like i would
[ __ ] if i'm investing in this huge movie
and i got these new guys i don't know
what they're about i'm not going to give
them [ __ ] a meal and be like oh yeah
well
[ __ ] well right i mean the idea is that
i didn't i didn't like perform what they
wanted you know and then it's like
pretty much a waste of their money so i
think it was kind of like let's see what
they got first and then maybe we'll
[ __ ] it's like
dude you're like i don't know when we
paid marcus you're like all right dude
this guy's in for it let's double it you
know well right but that's me like i
like uh the the the world doesn't
operate the way i do you know like the
mentality of yeah you're [ __ ] a
legend you're genius dude the the
mentality here is
did these kids get to be on jackass they
were like fans of jackass growing up and
now they get to be able to fight like we
don't have to pay themselves she'll do
it for free probably for free yes so you
know
um
so yeah they they got a little advantage
on their side you know for sure i mean
and they're not wrong i mean they're not
wrong it's like what are you gonna not
be in a big room oh sure you know like
it's like oh if you don't if you won't
do it for free then then i guess you're
not going to be in the movie of course
you're going to yeah [ __ ] i would be
like [ __ ] it i'd be like i'll do it for
free no right like like our buddy zeke
who i introduce you to who's just a
[ __ ] badass surfer yeah he kills
we've been hanging out a lot yeah jacob
zeke is achilles shout out to him yeah
shout out jake
he told me some crazy [ __ ] that you were
like telling him that you were like in
in
trouble with money
like
you know he was like yo we're trying to
drive somewhere and then oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] dude this [ __ ] life's hard right
now man there's a struggle out here you
were telling me like i didn't have any
gas money like i'm broke
dude
like i'm right now if i show you my bank
account it's in the
is
red
because you you're bad at spending or
just because you know you didn't have a
lot of money coming in
that jackass money because covid kept
hitting and hitting you know and we had
to get postponed and everything so like
through all those
you know
two years of living you got expenses you
got you know costs i mean i just
just living you know and all my all my
bills and [ __ ] just [ __ ] and you got
that new truck yeah i got my new truck i
needed my new truck though cause i
didn't have a car
and i was like dude there's one thing
i'm getting and it's my dream truck and
you're taking chicks out on dates and
you're like [ __ ] it i'm spending money
um there was a point when i was eating
really good yeah but i'd always think
you know i shouldn't have thought that
though i was always thinking no i'll be
fine you know i'll get another it'll
come back money come back you know right
but yeah [ __ ]
so dude let's the struggle's real dude
yeah let's uh let's figure out some
chunky are you on cameo i got cameo is
that uh that helps yeah
what are you charging for camera hundred
bucks okay
and uh how often are you getting them i
get one like um once a week maybe
okay can we
love my cameos dude they're like [ __ ]
psyched i get like 10 stars can we
please and i mean this genuinely
everybody listening
to this podcast can we please
get
cameo orders coming in for poopies
and t-shirt sales and can we please oh
dude i got i'm sitting on merch dude i
haven't sold a t-shirt i don't think in
like a month oh dude bro yeah those
shirts rule we gotta sell those shirts
where do we find those where did uh
yep so that's two s's in a row poopies
stores yeah there's two s's cool okay
and i got i got three shirts designs
presumably the store is linked in your
instagram bio yep so i got a whole link
tree of all my platforms okay so if you
click my link tree on my instagram bio
it'll take you to all of my stuff you
ever thought about doing it only fans
um i have but
i mean
i don't know how to do it
i don't like
only fans is like for chicks and like i
don't know dude i think
i think tiga tyga is like top three well
there's so many platforms like you could
is it how do you say really tiger tiger
yeah you guys want to see poopy dick
click here no
missionary like focusing like yeah yeah
yeah yeah they can watch your reach you
should do your cameos while you're
missionary like
no
i got kids fans so like i don't i like
the i love the groms we call them groms
is it the same surf shop that you talked
about going to when you dropped out of
school is still
still going still going it's corey
whitlock oh my god the whitlock surf
shop that was the one that was in
carlsbad across 7-eleven
yeah the first one that was the one next
to state beach and that's the one okay
that's where it all started at
whitlock's surf shop shout out to corey
whitlock yeah dude he's a legend but
yeah so those those t-shirts your your
first order of merch i was screen
printing those shirts wow that's crazy
what's the classic stevo design yeah
remember the ones that were done
the ones where people like would come
and then they would wash it once and
then all the ink would be gone yeah
because we didn't stamp them
just put them in the oven to like why
didn't you guys you're supposed to
double bake them too yeah they're like
they weren't baked so like that the ink
on the shirt was just smearing and i was
like dude [ __ ] yeah that was you that
was cool
and putting them on there this shop was
so classic they were like yeah we don't
we don't let our guys drink before 4 p.m
the order was late too or some [ __ ] like
so we had to [ __ ] rush him out bro i
remember staying up all night printing
your shirts dude like [ __ ] i hope i get
to meet steve oh dude [ __ ] dinner you
came and picked them up i think i was
gone when you picked them up and i came
back to their surf shop i was like [ __ ]
stevo came and got the shirts on cory's
like yeah i was like [ __ ] i like i
didn't get to meet [ __ ] steve i was
so devastated i did not not to worry man
yeah
i saw a clip of you on instagram like
way before
there was a jackass for like before
there was any idea about this and
i just loved that clip and so i reached
out to you and today i reached out and
said hey is it cool i put this clip
of it cool if i repost it you know i go
i thought it was fake at first like shut
the [ __ ] up like boys steve wants to
repost my [ __ ] so we uh started
following each other like way back
before yeah it was i was funny when i
did that i've i was doing a dance off
because it was like yeah we were doing
challenges right and we're just like a
dance off and whoever lost how to shave
their eyebrow so i was like [ __ ] this
i'm not [ __ ] losing i already got one
eyebrow off
so i was like dude
whatever i've got yeah so i was like i'm
not [ __ ] losing this one dude
so we're doing a dance off and this guy
does a back flip like on the ground i
was like oh [ __ ] so i'm like all right
doing my [ __ ] i see a [ __ ] toilet
brush over there i grab the toilet brush
i start brushing my teeth with the
toilet brush doing like some two-step
and then [ __ ] i'm like oh there's the
counter i planned this one out too
before i'm like i'm gonna do a front
flip off the [ __ ] counter so i get on
the counter like what the [ __ ] i'm like
yeah yeah yeah i'm like all right i kind
of count myself down like three two one
i [ __ ] flip and i kind of did it
perfectly where i didn't like knock my
head so hard that i get knocked out but
i kind of put all the weight on my
tailbone a little bit the tailbone to
the head dude standing on a kitchen
counter does a front flip lands flat on
his back on the ground like what four
feet below three feet below like yeah
jesus that [ __ ] looks so violent and
and you know he was in the worst [ __ ]
pain ever and it's devastating but
commitment to the performance he hops
back up and just fights through it doing
his dance there's a little moment where
you're like you're like ugh
dude am i paralyzed
okay i'm not i gotta finish this one off
guys
there's a distinct expression on your
face which says i'm not okay
but yeah i was in new zealand when that
and then i was like [ __ ] you reposted it
dude that day
bro i got so many [ __ ] followers i
was like yeah boys look at this [ __ ]
yeah they're like oh poopy's just
blowing up i was like [ __ ] yeah boys i'm
so stoked thank you yeah well hey dude i
mean dude you're you're lovable man
you're a lovable guy and uh and and you
know i'm rooting for you you know i've
been rooting for you yeah dude and i
just want uh i want you to get organized
i want you to to stick with it with your
content i want you to
run your videos by people for feedback
too yeah that's what i i always forget
to do that yeah and like you've put up
some videos on your chanel
that are [ __ ] whack yeah like that
where i feel like i feel like poopies if
you would
if you would have sent me a draft of
this video i could have given you some
notes and we could have worked on it a
little bit together we could have made
it a little better you know like i i get
a lot of eyeballs on my videos before i
put them out because i want to put them
out like
where it's like they're good
so this is yeah so next video i'm
sending it to you
yeah i will yeah
and uh we just flew you out to be on my
bucket list tour dude poopy's hit me up
and he says uh yo my family's in
springfield missouri are near there and
they want to come to your show is that
cool and i said please let's fly you out
to
be at that show with your family and
then let's bring you on the bus for a
couple cities we can hang out we can get
some footage then we'll send you home
from indianapolis which is where we are
now yep we're in indianapolis just had
to run you just did stand up comedy for
the first time just did stand up for the
first time this week and dude
i [ __ ] like it man
we put a couple grand in your pocket yep
stoked thank you so much
were you more nervous getting up on
stage for the first time or smuggling
hashish over the border uh smuggling
and just like
like [ __ ] up you know like saying it
wrong or just like pausing
you know what i mean just
stupid [ __ ] like that but they loved you
dude yeah dude thank you for that
opportunity and experience cause like i
never thought i'd ever be on tour with
you and i'd never ever thought i'd be on
the wild ride show
yeah
he gets so emotional
i love him
dad what a lovable kid man yeah it's
been it's crazy ah dude man poopies i
love you so much bro but yeah dude i do
stand up now and i [ __ ] kill it
yeah you do you guys want to book me you
guys can book me for stand up oh yeah
yeah it's crazy wild ride and uh instead
of saying your mom you didn't tell your
mom that you were no no i surprised her
yeah
so yeah i got video of surprising my mom
yeah for my chanel so i videoed all that
and i i've been doing little takes here
and there with my phone so and paul's
been helping me out with some clips yeah
last night him like meeting fans and
[ __ ] like that good yeah so it's been
good so i'm gonna go home take take all
the footage and send it to jack did you
get uh footage from our gas station bit
um yeah i didn't have that yes i have
that yeah
there's a bunch of stuff that we didn't
use i'm sure okay my video was like what
like
five six minutes maybe maybe yeah yeah
yeah i think um shane has it yeah shane
would have it
uh
editor and filmer yeah we got a lot of
footage that we need to go through and
like
yeah i want you to get organized yeah i
want you to you know
just like uh nobody thought that they
had to pay you much to be in in jackass
like nobody's gonna do the work for you
yeah definitely i'll help you every bit
that i can't be stopped but like i'm
telling you you gotta be
focused you got to be organized you got
to be motivated yeah you got to take
advantage of the opportunity that you
have right now yep and i think me being
sober helps out so much
yeah for real yes you should get sober
yeah
i've been drinking in [ __ ] five days
okay
you know you have a drinking problem
when you know the exact amount of days
alcoholism bro it's a disease dude it's
not it's hard to get rid of right all
right well yeah
yeah i will and i want to be better i
want to work on my stuff i want to come
out with better content every every week
and
yeah yeah i mean that's one thing you
are motivated for is is filming for your
chanel i love my chanel yeah it's like
that's how youtube
or how poopy spells channel
yeah for anyone who doesn't know what
everything is funny i was making my own
intro
yes the poopy's channel right and so
we'll wrap this up here okay with
another
um heartfelt
desperate plea
to get a lot of
cameos cameos and merch like i got my
merch in my filmers garage right now in
long beach ready to be sent out how
about if we take it a step further and
say what you're willing to do
for cameos maybe it's maybe it'll help i
mean you guys request whatever whatever
you want and i'll do it
first came out
my dad said i got an idea for you it's
called the executive dump
he said
he wanted me to
dress up like a
businessman in a suit and tie with
a briefcase and go to like a bus stop
where people are at the bus stop he says
and then you uh
you open up your briefcase
and
squat over it and take a [ __ ] in the
briefcase yeah you've got a roll of
toilet paper in the briefcase and you
could grab it and then wipe your butt
with the toy put it all back in the
briefcase and close it up and just like
like nothing happened and then
nonchalant and then and then like get on
the bus or whatever that's the next poop
yeah
yeah it's
when i surf the wedge in newport there's
no bathrooms at all and i usually get
there pretty early and i have to take a
morning dump every morning
so
i i've started like going showing up to
the wedge and like there's no bathroom
site i'd go [ __ ] find like a little
zone of [ __ ]
and it would be in front of public you
know it would usually be in the harbor
side where the rocks are but dude i was
like [ __ ] this one time i had an empty
shoe box
and i looked at my empty shoe box i was
like [ __ ] yeah dude i'm gonna poop in
the empty shoe box so i opened up my
side door set the shoe box down opened
it up took a [ __ ] in my shoe box i
didn't have any toilet paper i didn't
wipe
but i closed up my shoe box and threw it
in the trash can and i was like [ __ ] i'm
gonna do that every time i come to the
wedge so now every time i come to the
wedge i have an empty shoe box so i'd
take a [ __ ] in well
dude
executive [ __ ] but it's like you just
put your wetsuit on
all day the homeless yeah
yeah
that was yeah
yeah dude all right man everybody please
go get some poopies merch poopystore.com
poopystore.com fire up some poopies
cameos
fire those up i'm here i'm ready i'm and
i'll tell you i'm ready for those things
i'll take it a step further tag me in a
poopy's cameo and every single poopy's
cameo video i see on instagram which i'm
tagged in
i will
double tap it and i will leave a comment
to critique the poopiest performance
dude
please i'll even give maybe some
feedback like shut up like poopies you
know a little more energy on this one or
like okay dude that's huge dude thank
you
and the best idea that somebody gives
you to do for a cameo we'll send them
out a case of hot sauce
you guys so they got to be creative with
what they want to do
i'm good and
the people have to have fun creative to
get you to have fun with it yeah so we
had a little contest going here i like
it the cameo challenge all right
dude yeah i'll be stoked yeah dude
yeah we got you dude love you poops love
you too dude this has been a dream come
true dude
you put me on and dude i can't thank you
enough rob [ __ ] troops i'll tell you
how you can thank me dude [ __ ]
get clean it's over yep
i know
all right you guys have a great night
hell yeah later dude
ladies and gentlemen there you have it
that
was [ __ ] bombshell [ __ ] man and like
after we recorded that what two nights
ago i was like
it was weighing on me man i was just
laying in bed i was like dude
our boy poops
you know like
just want to help him you know i want to
help him i was stoked to have him on
tour i've been stoked to put them on my
main channel on my youtube and just kind
of pump them up try and show them how it
works and
ask you guys to help them out i really
would appreciate that like everything we
talked about
yeah jump on there man help help a boy
out poops is is a great kid
and it would mean a lot to me so yeah
street team i [ __ ] love you
and
thank you for sticking around yeah dude